what's up guys i'm jaden and i'm nessa
and we are going to be interviewing each
other as
super fans to find out more about one
another
so let's get into it
in your opinion what's the best jayden
song
right hey before it came out yet i
texted you and asked you to send it to
me
when i was back home because i just
wanted to cry in the shower
it is a good crystal what was your
first impression of my music i know this
looks gonna be so mean
i thought it was really good and i was
like oh this is sick it was like
weird for me because i didn't know you
did music there's someone was like this
is necessary i was like
who's nessa oh she makes music and we're
like yeah but no your music is fire but
then michael would come in i'm in
pain that was funny what do you think i
do better than
any other artists out there this is a
hard question
i could think of 80 machines i think
that you're very original
and you uh write dope lyrics
very creative original and i write
dopely
if you were to compare me to a music
legend living or
dead who would it be and why i hear a
lot of billy eilish i think she has a
lot of like
intensity in her voice but it's still
like quiet and i think
you do that that's hard you like whisper
when you sing yeah which is dope
it's really kind of weird i don't know
how she's saying some records but um
i assume how many songs of mine can you
name off the top of your head
if you can't do all of them you are just
bad at memories okay okay
tomatoes angels and demons tonight
better off dead prey am i missing
how many songs mine can you play from
the top of your head
pain and then is that the one is that
i'm in love is that it
i'm in i'm in something that three word
one i don't know what you're talking
about you have literally have
a song that has three words in it what
do you mean
let go he sucks daddy died
you forgot what i forgot if you loved me
it would have been bad if you
didn't forget one of mine but i only
have three songs
which lyric from one of my songs is
absolute fire
all of them i'll give you help it's from
angels and demons that has to be like
so far the ones that i have literally
can't wait i think
i'm like a rock star that's the only one
i know from that heart
what's your absolute favorite necessary
music video
lottie die true that one it's different
that one's hard
andrew killed that one like i actually
really liked that video like i thought
i was sick i was really just kind of
like just sprinkle i didn't do much
i just like danced when you hear my name
what's the first thing that comes to
your mind i don't know how to explain it
but when i hear
words or names i think of colors and so
jaden's would be black i just think of
the color black
if i decided to change my stage name
what should i change it to
i feel like uh 28
yeah it's a number but it's still if you
had to pick another
artist for me to collab with who would
it be and why
i'd like to see you collab with like a
girl i think that'd be really cool
yeah depending on like who it is and i'm
saying like miley's song would do it
it's like really dope what's your
favorite jaden moment
on lottie die it has to be the scream i
think the screen was dope
it's just dope to do things that people
don't really expect i think that scream
really like
was something no for sure but like it's
like not a pop thing to do you know
radio and stuff so that's why it's cool
for me to like hear my screen and stuff
on the radio
yeah you know uh what's your favorite
nessa moment online
i don't know i thought it was really
cool that you just asked me to be on it
i thought that was hard i remember i
thought you were just showing me the
song i'm like oh this is sick and then
shannon was like she wants you to be on
it yeah it was actually so funny because
like we were listening to it
and janet was like this is dope the
future would be cool on it and then just
walked out
i was like oh i had no idea i was like
dude
thank you buzzfeed so much for having us
and thank you guys for watching
make sure to streamline and watch
our music video thank you guys peace bye
you